While it’s commonly stated that the practice
of marking important dates in red didn’t
begin until the Middle Ages, in fact, in ancient
Rome red ink was sometimes used on calendars
to identify significant dates, as well as
occasionally used on important text in documents,
with the underlying reason in both cases seemingly
being the same as today- to make the text
stand out, in the case of the calendar marking
a noteworthy day.
Through the years this practice continued,
and in particular with medieval scribes who
used red ink in much the same fashion for
initial capital letters and certain important
words (called rubrics) in their illuminated
manuscripts.
As writing became more widespread, others
quickly adopted the use of red ink in their
writing, too, as noted by John Trevisa in
Polychron (1387): “we writep capital letters
wip reed colour.”
Likewise, particularly important days, such
as a saints’ feast or one of the holy days,
were identified on medieval church calendars
with the color red.
It was first identified in English by William
Caxton in The boke yf Enyeydos (1490): “We
wryte yet in
oure kalenders the hyghe festes wyth red lettres
of colour of purpre.”
In 1549, the first Book of Common Prayer included
a calendar with the holy days marked in red,
thus spurring use of the phrase; however,
the first print reference to red-letter day
is not seen until 1663, when Edmund Gayton
wrote in The religion of a physician: “the
Red-letter daies being the Ornament of her
Year.”
Using the term in reference to a secular day
is first seen in The Journals of Madam Knight
in which Sarah Kemble Knight (1666-1727) wrote:
“Their Chief Red Letter day is St. Election,
wch is annually Observed according to Charter,
to choose their Govnr.”
Notably, even today in England there remains
an official practice of recognizing certain
special days as “Red Letter days,” such
as the Queen’s birthday and some saints’
days, at least with its High Court; on these
days, all High Court judges wear scarlet robes,
while on ordinary days, only judges hearing
criminal cases wear the long red garments.
Because the rest of the calendar was written
in black ink, ordinary days used to commonly
be referred to as black-letter days; for example,
Tobias Smollett wrote in The tars of old England.
A Comedy (1757): “O! the month of November,
She’ll have cause to remember As a black
letter day all the days of her life.”
The legal phrase black-letter law, meaning
well-established, basic principles of law
that are no longer up for debate, traces its
history to at least 1831 when the US Supreme
Court wrote in Jackson v. Huntington, 30 U.S.
402: “It is seldom that a case in our time
savors so much of the black letter, but the
course of decision in New York renders it
unavoidable.”
Interestingly, the phrase does not derive
from Black’s famous dictionary or the color
of the ink.
Rather, black-letter refers to an old-fashioned
form of type that used to be called blackletter,
but today is known generally as Gothic, – a
formal, difficult-to-read script that, as
it was used for all legal printing well into
the 18th Century, symbolized both the law
and the authority of the State.
In fact, even though Roman type had been adopted
for most English printing during the Renaissance,
legal printers purposely retained their nearly
unintelligible Gothic script, at least in
part because lawyers liked keeping the fundamentals
of the law to themselves.[1]
Many attribute the changeover to William Blackstone
who broke with tradition and published his
famous Commentaries on the Laws of England
(1765-1769) in Roman type.
As the Commentaries soon became the go-to
treatise for lawyers of the age, it influenced
others to begin publishing law books in the
far easier-to-read Roman type as well; this
was, perhaps, not so much because Blackstone
was the premiere authority on English law,
but rather because his book was far easier
to decipher than other, earlier texts.